microsoft airbus ou encore vinci ces
sociétés pourraient s'ajouter à la liste
des entreprises qui ont choisi
d'employer des détenus le principal
argument au travail carcéral serait
d'aider les prisonniers pour leur retour
à la vie active réduisant la récidive
mais en quoi consiste cette pratique est
elle réellement efficaces pour leur
réinsertion
[Musique]
pourquoi fait-on travail et des
prisonniers pour l'institut montaigne la
sanction pénale doit permettre de
réinsérer les condamnés dans la société
et l'enjeu est grand avec une densité
carcérale qui s'élèvent à plus de 115 %
surtout quand on considère qu 31% des
sortants de prison de l'année 2016 ont à
nouveau été condamné pour une infraction
commise dans l'année de leur libération
et parmi eux
79% sont sanctionnés d'une nouvelle
peine d'emprisonnement ferme en france
depuis 1987 le travail des détenus n'est
plus obligatoire en revente d'après le
code de procédure pénale dans les
établissements pénitentiaires toutes
dispositions sont prises pour assurer
une activité professionnelle aux
personnes incarcérées qui le souhaitent
et cette activité professionnelle qui
est proposé aux prisonniers se
départagent en deux catégories il ya
deux types de travail en prison il ya ce
qu'on appelle d'abord le service général
ont fait c'est travailler pour
l'administration pénitentiaire et
assurer les fonctions donc le ménage
entretien d des cours de promenade par
exemple puis fonction de potel riz
blanchisserie ensuite vous avez le
travail qu'on appelle en concession pour
des ateliers de l'administration
pénitentiaire ou pour des des
entreprises privées qui vont amener le
le matériel pour le travail à faire et
puis qui repartiront avec les objets
faits ou fabriqués par les dpu 80 kg est
très répétitif à très gratifiant ni
formateur en fait quand on se penche
d'un peu plus près sur les conditions on
se rend compte que les prisonniers n'ont
pas de contrat de travail les relations
de travail des personnes incarcérées ne
font pas l'objet d'un contrat de travail
en moyenne compter entre 2 euros et 4
euros 50 de l'heure pour le salaire d'un
détenu et leurs revenus varient en
fonction de la technicité de la tâche
c'est donc un avantage pour l'entreprise
qui s'offrent une main d'oeuvre à bas
prix concernant l'émission qui dépendent
beaucoup de la localisation du centre de
détention on peut proposer aux détenus
de mettre des oignons en sachet mais
aussi de fabriquer du mobilier pour le
centre en question ou encore de
fabriquer des équipements de sécurité
pour les agents du ministère de la
justice il en revanche le travail
pénitentiaire a évolué il propose aussi
des tâches qui correspondent à un public
plus jeune en valorisant des ateliers
numériques par exemple certains détenus
travaillent pour des centres d'appels ou
encore pour la numérisation de documents
de l'ina en moyenne en 2010 8 environ
dix neuf mille personnes disposaient
d'un emploi en détention pour plus de
70000 personnes incarcérées
46,2 % des détenus était embauché en
2000 et en 2020 ce taux est passé à 28 %
d'après l'oip bien que les entreprises
et des avantages divers en employant des
prisonniers on constate que le travail
pénitentiaire a évolué plutôt à la
baisse au cours de ces 100 dernières
années jusqu'en 2008 qui avait 600
entreprises qui donnait du travail en
détention et qu'en 2018 on s'est
retrouvé à plutôt 300 entreprises entre
temps il ya quand même eu ni crise
économique assez importante et
aujourd'hui on remonte la pente on est à
peu près 450 entreprises qui qui
acceptent de donner du travail ce qui
est aussi intéressant de voir c'est
comment aussi les entreprises
sont un peu plus intéressés par ce
travail pénitentiaire parce que ça
rentre dans l'eure
dans leur rce
rse pardon c'est à dire dans ce qu'elles
doivent faire pour pour la pour la
communauté citoyenne et donc travail le
travail pénitentiaire entre dans ce
cadre dans ce cas de figure à la vue de
ces éléments très partagés il est
légitime de se demander si le travail
carcéral est réellement bénéfique pour
les détenus si cette opportunité limite
le risque de récidive une fois sorti de
prison tout d'abord le travail en prison
doit permettre dans la mesure du
possible d'entretenir ou d'augmenter la
capacité du détenu a gagné sa vie après
sa sortie de prison en résumé le travail
en prison doit offrir de nouvelles
perspectives aux détenus à l'issue de
leur période de détention
donc pour éviter qu'il tombe dans leurs
travers passés en récidivant cette étude
publiée en 2007 sur le lien entre le
travail en détention et le risque de
récidive souligner le fait que
l'inactivité professionnelle renforcé
des déficits sociaux et personnels déjà
présents et augmentent ainsi le risque
d'un acte délictueux
cette étude nous avons constaté que le
taux de récidive baisse de manière
significative entre 20 et 50 x force est
de constater que la mission de
réinsertion par le travail n'est pas une
priorité puisque l'administration
pénitentiaire est en train de faire du
travail un instrument pour combattre la
pauvreté un des critères prioritaires de
classement devient l'indigence du
demandeur et non son avenir
professionnel
ce qui est certain c'est que si à la
sortie de détention de ces publics
souvent très précarisés il ya la
possibilité de travailler il ne
récidiveront pas mais si derrière il n'y
a pas la possibilité d'être embauchée je
pense que la vraie difficulté du travail
pénitentiaire c'est l'après dans une
seconde étude plus récente publiée par
le ministère de la justice et porte et
elle sur les raisons expliquant la
récidive le travail en prison réduit
légèrement la probabilité de récidive et
un seul système qui valorise l'effort le
travail l'apprentissage de la lecture
les chemins chico thérapie rien que le
fait de se lever le matin
alors pour certains jeunes c'est un
effort qui sera prise en compte même si
le travail carcéral seul ne répondent
pas forcément à la problématique de la
récidive puisque son efficacité peut
être pointé du doigt le garde des sceaux
eric dupond moretti dans le cadre de la
loi pour la confiance dans l'institution
judiciaire qui souhaite réformer le
travail dans les prisons parmi les
objectifs fixés favoriser la réinsertion
professionnelle renforcé les droits liés
au travail améliorer l'image du travail
pénitentiaire et attirer des entreprises
plus d'impliquer dans l'objectif de
réinsertion des personnes détenues avec
des emplois plus qualifiés
après ces quelques éléments qu'on a mis
en lumière la réforme du garde des
sceaux répond exactement aux
problématiques du travail carcéral
puisque les risques de récidive sont
atténuées lorsqu un rythme de vie stable
une rémunération et surtout une
formation sont offertes aux déjà un
environnement social disons
sur lequel andy murray qui insistent et
espère qu'il permettra de lutter contre
la récidive parce que en fait où but un
peu contre la précarité et ont fait une
suite on donne suite à ce qui a pu se
faire en détention
[Musique]
et